that's the way I felt when the engine
light came on my car because I knew
there was no money to pay it and you
have all these Americans now who are
living hand to mouth hey guys I'm off
the grid for August but the last sane
Democrat and I'm pretty sure I mean that
literally RFK Jr making sense as always
to fund these wars that were you know
we're funding
they print money and that means
inflation and that's the tax on the poor
oh the price of food has gone up by 38
the price of basic foodstuffs
I'm chicken eggs and milk have gone up
78 so his food stamps were 78 you know
less valuable
on March 1st of this year he got a phone
call
from the a government phone call
robocall
the recorded voice told him that he was
getting his food stamps got to twenty
thirty dollars a month so 90 percent
30 million Americans got that phone call
and um you know that's the same month
we Ratched it ratcheted up our
contributions to the Ukraine at to
Ukraine at 30 at 113 billion
and we print the FED printed 300 billion
unanticipated dollars to pay for the
failure of the Silicon Valley Bank
there's lots of money for for and we and
we we began cutting
15 million people from the route welfare
rules since then 4 million have been cut
this is on Politico this morning from
from the Medicare Rose
oh there's no money for poor Americans
and the people that I see are living
because of the inflation and because of
what's happening at this with this
desperation
the average wage in this country is now
five thousand dollars left
less and the cost of um of basic Goods
of food transportation and housing
so half of Americans are making up that
Gap by putting it on their credit card
bills and this week we pass
1.1 trillion dollars in credit card debt
that's the first time in history most of
that
or 330 billion that has been in the
Biden the Trump Administration two men
were saying I you know I'm helping
America
the trillion dollar credit card debt and
those people are paying 22 percent
interest if the mafia did that it would
be called loan sharking not
dischargeable in bankruptcy by the way
right and it can't be discharged oh
you're I'm meeting people
who are you know couples who are sitting
at their dining room tables
and trying to figure out how how this
math works for them because they can't
they're they're having to make choices
people in this country
are choosing between food and gasoline
and and food and Medicine
and they're they're listening to a
little baby crying in the room next to
our young couples
and having to have to wonder where that
baby is 50 sick or 100 sick or 500 or
1500 sake before they bring them to a
hospital and you know my wife
and I were talking about the other night
and we were talking about this epidemic
of depression and mental illness and
anxiety that is afflicting Americans in
the deterioration that sense the wheels
are falling off and she said you know
that's the way I felt when she was
living in poverty she said that's the
way I felt when the engine light came on
my car because I knew there was no money
to pay it and you have all these
Americans now who are living hand to
mouth and uh and they do not feel
that anybody is listening to them in the
political process they feel they've been
completely abandoned by the Democratic
party and the Republican party and that
those parties are now serving Elites
and um and that uh you know their voices
aren't being heard and particularly now
you know the Democratic party has had
this very interesting shift where when I
grew up
um my when my uncles my father was in
the Democratic party was with people who
were poor
and working people are and today
70 of the wealth in this country is
owned by the Democratic party and only
30 percent the Republican Party
the top 10 counties in the top richest
counties in this country nine of the ten
are Democratic counties so there is this
kind of shift in in uh in wealth that
maybe is one of the reasons that uh
Democrats do not seem to be
talking to or for working people anymore